13 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
feel on the App Store or Google Play
I'm Joanna sir and today we'll be
focusing on your lower body so this is
going to be a strength and conditioning
workout to work on your thighs your
hamstrings your glutes as well as your
outer and inner thighs so we'll be doing
lots of squats as well as lunges
[Music]
let's start with a quick warm-up to get
your legs ready so specially with the
public at host pointed forward let's go
for squats okay nice and easy
drop your butt back and down squeeze it
right at the top nice keep a chest open
and look straight ahead very good so
push your butt back and drive it up good
now let's go deeper okay
go lower go deeper making sure that your
knee and your toes are in line good give
me five more squat squeeze your glutes
right at the top up squeeze engage the
glute muscles last two more squeeze one
more squeeze and now let's go for whew
reverse lunges okay now station with the
pod step back and I want you to reach up
and feel your upper body being stretched
out as well step forward back stretch up
forward back forward and back okay so
open up your chest feel your back being
stretched out and feel your thighs
getting warmed up as well
good give me three more on each side
last two more whew remember to pace your
breathing breathe last one more and okay
shake it out now few more hamstring
stretches okay so just place your
fingers underneath your toes squat down
up push your butt back down straighten
your legs
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
straight down up two more down plus one
down and up okay first workout grab your
dumbbells
the first workout is going to be goblet
squat so stay sugar with a pot toes
pointed forward grab the dumbbells hold
them close to you
squat down again chest up squeeze your
gluts right at the top okay squeeze and
back down so what I'm going to do is
making sure that the dumbbells are
directly in front of you do not hunched
forward this is wrong okay chest up and
up squeeze good if you feel that this is
too tough you can always stop the
workout without any dumbbells so just
using your bodyweight squeeze back down
up and rest it out good okay so now drop
the dumbbells we want to go for a few
squad pulses and a jam okay so it's
going to be a strength workout with an
explosive movement catch your breath
breathe in and breathe out let's go
three squat pulses one two three and a
jump good one two three and a jump again
if you want to you can only go with the
squad pulses to begin with up drive your
legs up push using your thighs squeeze
your gluts right at the top nice three
squat pulses and hop good up back down
that's ten more seconds
up down last two more one more
squat pulses and rest it up hah shake
your legs alright let's go back to our
dumbbells okay choose your option you
can start this with or without dumbbells
reverse lunges both dumbbells just by
your side okay then sugar with the pot
and I'm going to bring your left leg
back to begin with okay left leg back
step back forward now right side and
forward okay good
so pushing through your front heel
up step back pushing through a front
heel back and up good any workouts you
want to always make sure that your
posture is upright okay so stand tall
look straight ahead driving through your
front heel push it nice step back push
it whoop few more that's two more last
one bar and drop the dumbbells okay
reverse lunge with a me up okay so again
what we want to do is get into reverse
lunge with me up this will also work on
your core muscles okay so let's just
start with our left leg let's go down up
drive the knee up
down and up to keep your balance look at
one point okay look straight ahead look
at one point and just feel your right
leg doing all the work
especially your glutes up down up
squeeze right at the top squeeze bring
your knee as high up as possible nice
crunch a core as you lift your knee
straight up very good
last one more and rest it up okay shake
it out a little bit okay no the other
side so we've worked on our right leg
let's work on our left leg okay remember
to breathe in and breathe out good okay
let's get ready
shut it with the pad stand forward look
straight ahead okay all right go up drop
your right leg back and bring it up
squeezing and feeling the intensity on
your left glute good back down and up
push through your heels okay knee as
high as possible crunch a core feel your
core engaged ah
down up you should feel that one leg is
usually slightly weaker than the other
up done it up give me two more down up
down up down and okay very good
now breathe in breathe out
we are taking a one-minute break okay
and we want to repeat all five exercises
again so grab some water wipe your sweat
and just take this time to bring your
heart rate back down
boom
I want you to remember that this workout
is based on your abilities okay if you
are a beginner and if you feel that this
is too tough for me then start this
entire workout without any dumbbells
just use your own bodyweight as you
progress then start to lift a little bit
light say two to three kilos each and
eventually go for medium weight between
four to five kilos each okay so we have
about fifteen seconds rest first workout
is going to be goblet squat okay
remember that the dumbbells should be in
the middle it should not be out here
okay right in the middle focus on your
legs and your glutes alright grab the
dumbbells stand tall
let's go up and squeeze okay about
shoulder width apart and squeeze good
back down squeeze the glutes all right
down and squeeze good remember hold for
one second right at the top down and
squeeze keeping your back flat and
straight good back down squeeze
dumbbells right in the middle all right
good
keep going last two more a bit squeeze
last one more squeeze and drop the
dumbbells all right
choose your option you can either just
stay with squat pulses or add a jump
into it okay or just go for regular
squats breathe in breathe out
three squat pulses with one squad Jam
okay let's go one two three jump it up
one two three oh I remember to breathe
up as you jump up down
good halfway there strong legs okay
strong thighs strong legs
remember to learn with your knees soft
and bent squat pulses go low ten more
seconds
hop last few more last one more humph
and rest it out good job okay let's grab
our dumbbells I feel the burn okay I can
feel your legs burning and crying right
now
reverse lunges with dumbbells right step
forward toes pointed straight forward
let's go left leg back down push up
through your heels and down okay
pushing through your front heel and up
go as low as you can
legs 90 degrees up back drive up and up
you are halfway there
this is the second set for the first
circuit you are strong okay every time
you push that's when you're working on
your legs keep going
last one more on each side one and rest
it out
okay drop the weights okay all right
reverse lunge with knee up if you want
to challenge yourself you can add a
small hop right at the top all right
so choose your option oh my heart is
racing right now let's go down and up up
down up or stop without a hop knee up
okay I want you to focus on your balance
focus on your core as you progress down
hop working on your fights even more as
well as your cuff muscles down it up
just a small hop
all right go heads in your car hop it up
good keep going last three more okay
last two more one more and rest it up
change the other side okay whoa just
that extra hop it will really burn your
glutes Oh shake it out shake it out
one last workout and we're going to take
a one-minute break before moving on to
the second circuit alright ready let's
go right leg back drag your knee up back
drive the knee up okay as high as you
can keep going up and now let's add a
hop good a small hop whoa stay with me
last workout and you're gonna get a
one-minute break hop 15 seconds left
okay hop hop find your balance look at
one point last three more last two more
one more and
rest it out alright take a one-minute
break and we want to move on to second
number two
breathe in breathe out bring your heart
rate back down
remember to always keep yourself
hydrated okay oh you have about 30
seconds left
all right the next workout will be
working on your alpha as well as your
inner thighs what I want to do is step
wide with the toes pointed out and your
knees pointed out okay so when you squat
done you're in a deep sumo squat
position again you can do this workout
without any dumbbells or we're going to
grab two dumbbells okay so choose your
option right keep both dumbbells right
in the middle step white and now let's
go down whew your outer thighs and your
inner thighs as you squat down and up
good squeeze your glutes right at the
top okay so feel the stretch on both
outer inner thighs as well as your outer
glutes squeeze it back down squeeze down
up squeeze really squeeze and hope a one
count right at the top push it thrust
your hip forward
good down up and drop the dumbbells okay
good
next workout it's going to be super
squad pulses with a criss cross all
right so take the time to breathe in and
out we want to go low and go deep and
hop right back up all right let's go
one two three criss-cross one two three
criss-cross that's it okay so hop low
and crisscross right at the top good
crisscross two three two three if this
is too tough again you can just step in
step out one two three step in step out
one two three okay so choose your option
in and out
you are still doing the workout and you
will still be a steep active ok last one
and rat okay now grab your mat we want
to lie down and work on hip thrust okay
so spread your mat out lie straight down
alright place both dumbbells right on
your hips drive up control it down drive
up squeeze it back down
up squeeze good back down
so this dumbbells will add extra
intensity to work on your gluts up and
back down you want to make sure that
your legs are 90 degrees right at the
top okay so do not step too far out step
in close up back down drop it up down up
back down and up again
last few more and rest it out okay drop
the dumbbells come back up and get into
all fours
all right get into ovals and let's work
on donkey kicks let's start with our
left leg to begin with okay so this is
going to be an isolation glute workout
focusing on one side bring it up kick it
up bring you down
up squeeze hold for one count right at
the top pushing up through your heels
bring it back down up okay bye now
to be honest you will not need any
weights at all because you have been
working on your gluts
for the past 15 minutes up back down
control up nice and strong core keep
your back flat and keep your neck
neutral by looking straight down so
avoid looking forward okay look straight
down drive it up back down nice and
controlled do not just let your leg drop
okay good now switch the other side
right
leg-oh to make sure that your car is
strong you want to make sure that your
pumps and your knees are sugar with a
pot okay and keep them keep them
grounded on the floor throughout okay
let's go right leg up pushing through
your heels up squeeze good minimal
movement on the upper body up and back
it down squeeze it up look at my sweat
just dripping on the mat back down up
drive it up back down and up
whoo I can feel my butt burning and
that's the sensation that we want keep
going you have ten seconds left and you
will get a one-minute break right after
this keep going back down up push it up
and now take a one-minute break whoo
look at my sweat you should be sweating
like this okay let me know in the
comments below if you are drenched in
sweat take this time to breathe and just
get into a child's pose keep breathing
bring a hum rate down
we have one final circuit to go okay we
want to repeat all the workouts once
more stretch out good okay I'm going to
wipe my sweat
huh it's like I just came out of the
shower all right okay you have about 20
seconds lap okay so again with sumo
squad the main thing is to keep your
toes and your knees pointed out the most
common mistake I see is people doing
this not stepping wide enough you got to
make sure that you're stepping wide
enough yet you have the strong core
right in the center okay so go down and
squeeze up go down and thrust your hips
slightly forward and squeeze your glutes
okay so grab the dumbbells
let's go up cross it back down and up
all right
so you should be down run slightly
forward squeeze down thrust good back
down and squeeze so you're working on
the inner thighs and the outer part of
your glutes good keep going down quick
dig deep okay go low and up good go low
up nice go low and up last one more low
and up good drop the dumbbells all right
next sumo squat pulses with tiptoe okay
so three pulses and tiptoe on the fourth
count all right your heart rate should
be pumping okay my Hydra is at 165 right
now that's crazy so one two three
tiptoe work on your cuffs one two three
tiptoe working on your cuffs two three
ah
okay stay low bu the stretch on the
inner thighs tiptoe and down good up
nice remember to breathe out as you come
up without squeezing your cuffs it's a
really good cuff toning workout one two
three
tiptoe last one two three
tiptoe and back down nice okay let's lie
straight down okay grab your dumbbells
and get down onto the mat all right
place your dumbbells gently on your hips
okay and now remember remember to bring
your heels closer to your body drive it
up
ready go down and up
so control down and fuss up squeeze hold
it and back down squeeze for one count
and down so you should also feel the
stretch and work on your hamstrings down
and just look straight up up good back
down up back down squeeze it okay right
nice now let's just stay up and go left
then right left and right come on work
your glutes left and right ah
and now drop the dumbbells donkey kicks
alright okay so let's do this face
forward
keep your palms spread out nice firmly
and ground it on the floor let's lift
your left leg up push it bring it back
down up tuck it in drive it in crunch it
and back up okay let's go all the way
crunch it in and push it back up good
you should feel the contraction on your
gluts right at the top if you do not
feel it then you got to go higher okay
push through your heels and lift it
higher good on the final ten seconds we
want to go four pulses okay all right so
hold it let's go one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten one two oh it's
burning now let's balance it out on the
other side okay all right
my sweat is dripping Oh breathe in and
breathe out find a workout final set and
you are done for the day 30 minutes of
solid workout let's go bring it up drive
it in
crunch it in push your heels straight up
crunch it in crunch a core straight up
and in
push good working on your right glute
good strong okay keeping your shoulders
strong as well good up whoo
drive it up let's go keep going give me
two more and on the final ten seconds
let's go for pulse of state up two three
four five six push it seven eight nine
ten last two one two oh all right okay
now let's get into a child's pose just
take this time to relax do the stretch
on your lower back as well as your
glutes
all right what a workout I am drenched
in sweat and my legs are on fire this is
a really effective workout to work on
your entire lower body your thighs your
glutes your hamstrings your hips as well
as your inner thighs
so do this workout regularly and combine
this with my other workout videos and
trust me in no time you will have a
stronger legs more toned and also a
firmer and lifted glutes don't forget to
like this video share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos
fitness tips as well as delicious
recipes all the best